okay before we go to break in the debate
yesterday the last presidential debate
between Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
the issue of the rigged election came up
I believe that this was Donald Trump's
weakest moment during the debate and
this was Hillary Clinton strongest
moment from the debate absolutely
destroying what it is that Donald Trump
is saying Donald Trump first asked will
you accept the results of this election
no matter what they are here is Donald
Trump's answer your running mate
governor pence pledged on Sunday that he
and you his words will absolutely accept
the result of this election today your
daughter Ivanka said the same thing I
want to ask you here on this stage
tonight do you make the same to dip into
you will absolutely sir that you will
absolutely accept the result of this
election I will look at it at the time
I'm not looking at anything now I'll
look at it at the time what I've seen
what I've seen is so bad first of all
the media is so dishonest and so corrupt
and the pile-on is so amazing the New
York Times they actually wrote an
article about it that they don't even
care it's so dishonest and they've
poisoned the minds of the voters but
unfortunately for them I think the
voters are seeing through it I think
they're going to see through we'll find
out on November it but I think they're
going to see better concert there's a
look excuse me because if you look at
your voter rolls you will see millions
of people that are registered to vote
millions this isn't coming from me this
is coming from pure report in other
places millions of people that are
registered to vote that shouldn't be
registered to vote so let me just give
you one other things I talk about the
corrupt media I talk about the millions
of people tell you one other thing she
shouldn't be allowed to run its crook
she's she's guilty of a very very
serious crime she should not be allowed
to run yeah does anyone understand the
explanation here I mean on the one hand
Trump is saying the election is rigged
because of millions of of of people dead
people all sorts of people who shouldn't
be registered to vote well that's been
debunked then he says the rigging is the
fact that media outlets publish opinion
pieces and or fact-based p
is that are not good for Trump's
campaign that's not really rigging
that's called reporting and you might
not agree with some of it and then he
says part of the evidence of rigging is
that Hillary Clinton is even a candidate
because as he says she is guilty of a
crime Trump apparently not understanding
the definition of guilt because Hillary
Clinton has not even been accused of a
crime which is a step that is necessary
that needs to happen before you can be
found guilty of a crime Hillary Clinton
destroyed Trump with her follow up on
this issue take a look what I'm saying
is that I will tell you at the time I'll
keep you in suspense well let me respond
to that because that's horrifying you
know every time Donald thinks things are
not going in his direction he claims
whatever it is is rigged against him the
FBI conducted a year-long investigation
into my emails they concluded there was
no case he said the FBI was rigged he
lost the Iowa caucus he lost the
Wisconsin primary he said the Republican
primary was rigged against him then
Trump University gets sued for fraud and
racketeering he claims the court system
and the federal judge is rigged against
him there was even a time when he didn't
get an Emmy for his TV program three
years in a row and he started tweeting
that the Emmys were rigged shoulda
gotten this this is a mindset this is
this is how Donald thinks and it's funny
but it's also really troubling okay that
is not the way our democracy works we've
been around for 240 years we've had free
and fair elections we've accepted the
outcomes when we may not have liked them
and that is what must be expected of
anyone standing on a debate stage during
a general election you know President
Obama said the other day when you're
whining oh hold on cloaks and hold on
folks it just shows you you're not up to
doing the job absolutely strong answer
from Hillary Clinton Donald Trump's
entire rigged election thing is a major
repudiation repudiation excuse me of
American democracy at its core
republican governors
agree with Trump on this and we're gonna
dig in much more to the rigged election
stuff let's take a break I am joining
you today from Las Vegas Nevada the site
of last night's third and final
presidential debate gamefly is sort of
like Netflix for video games they have
over 8,000 new and classic games for
xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 wii and a
bunch of other platforms and you can
play as many games as you want for one
monthly fee and if you find some games
you want to keep you can buy them for a
low use price there's never any due
dates or late fees and our audience can
get a free 30-day trial at gamefly
offer.com / TDPS the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the david
pakman show audience and support our
show by going to gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s